in 1990 the number of men who said they
had zero close friends was around about
three percent 2020 that number was
fifteen percent that's insane the most
common answer to the question how many
friends could you call on in an
emergency is zero it's not the average
but it's the most common more people
have zero friends to call on than have
any other number the challenge of modern
masculinity relates to that addiction
quote the belief that you can find
fulfillment alone and you see this in
the the sigma male Meme Over the Top of
a lot of this metamine which is being
created is a guy called Chris Bumstead
who is a four-time classic physique
Champion Mr Olympia I sit down with
Chris this guy who is the face of the
sigma male Meme and I asked him how much
of what you've done and achieved in
business in personal life and in your
sport could you have done on your own
zero I could have done none of it the
belief that you can find fulfillment
alone is a lie that people who have been
hurt and scorned and rejected by the
world Retreat into